and we begin with this a green beret is
taking his battle to su army doctors all
the way to Congress even as he battles
for his own life active-duty service
members cannot sue for medical
malpractice or negligence because of a
1950 Supreme Court decision known as the
Feres doctrine the House passed a new
provision in the annual National Defense
Authorization Act or NDAA that could
partly overturn that decision Jan
Crawford spoke with the sergeant leading
this charge nearly a decade after his
last overseas deployment army sergeant
Richard stay school is fighting a new
battle it's definitely one of the bigger
more challenging ones I've ever been a
part of going back to Iraq in many ways
that seems almost easier a green beret
and former Marine Stace Cole was wounded
in Iraq in 2004 now he's fighting cancer
and a legal roadblock known as the Feres
doctrine the courthouse doors are
totally shut to our military that's
correct they don't have a legal rate or
have any legal recourse when it comes to
my practice attorney Natalie qualm
represents dozens of service members
blocked from suing the military for
malpractice or negligence the spirit of
that law was that if you were in combat
the initial law was to protect those
medics and such from being sued for
malpractice in combat in combat in war
the rulings broad application is given
stay school almost no recourse after he
says doctors at Fort Bragg's Womack Army
Hospital ignored a tumor growing in his
lung I knew deep down there was
something was not right he says when he
was allowed to see a civilian specialist
in June of 2017 he found out army
doctors had noted the growth at two
separate appointments but did nothing my
pulmonologists out in town he was
actually the one who asked why nobody
told us six months ago would that have
made a difference do you think he said
he truly believed he down that six
months of early notice it would have
been a big difference did they give you
any prognosis then I think I took it as
like a flu I was like okay we'll just
get this thing fixed it's no big deal
everybody else knew differently what's
the prognosis now right now I'm stage
four I'm terminally ill it's not just
medical malpractice army nurse Katie
Blanche's case also is blocked I did
everything right I went to the people
that I could go to I asked for help
I made my command to where and they
failed me Blanchard was working as a
hospital supervisor at Fort Leavenworth
in Kansas when at an erratic employee
and she had repeatedly discussed with
supervisors doused her with gasoline and
lit her on fire I went through a phase
where I almost wish I didn't went
through it just because of how difficult
it was and how I couldn't be with my
children how I wanted to be Blanche's
attacker was sent to prison but she says
her former supervisors have been
promoted and the system that allowed her
attack and others hasn't changed the
military that I knew and that I loved
and then my family loved had left me
behind I knew that if I lived I wanted
to change the system I want to welcome
everyone in April she was in the
audience as state school testified
before the House Armed Services
Subcommittee chaired by California
Democrat Jackie Speier I have what's
called an outrage meter and when it goes
off in a way that gives me heartburn
I know I have to do something those
efforts help get a narrow exception to
the Feres doctrine passed in the house
now that it's up to the Senate state
school is using the time he has left to
keep fighting for change I'm unable to
continue serving downrange and overseas
in that capacity but I'm not done
serving my country it's a fight bigger
than you
absolutely what if it doesn't go through
that's a tough one I don't I don't want
to believe that it's not gonna go I feel
like it's gonna happen I have to I want
to now when Congress gets back to work
here in September state school says he
hopes the language that carries his name
will make it into that final legislation
but even if it does it will only apply
to cases of medical malpractice cases
involving negligence like Blanchard's
still will be blocked from going to
trial for CBS this morning I'm
Jan Crawford boy representative spear is
right that really does pique your
outrage meter I think anybody who hears
that I don't I was thinking exact same
thing why you're outraged meter it
doesn't just explode when you hear
Richard annales tours yeah here you're
walking around one story
final days of his life stage four he's
terminal he's fighting any believes
leads